well the fun never ends because um Oh
Don McLean is broken down and there is
the issue of filling up some gaps in
this park because no it's quite empty
here in there and I don't really know
what to do with that so for one there is
this area behind the roller coaster and
there's this there is that Q line what
the hell get rid of that and I
definitely want to fill this area up and
I kind of want to remove that because
that's just one big pimp over there like
okay though there we go also yeah if you
want to mow your grass so you don't want
to have Hanuman because honey man suck
at mowing grass you can just use this
and mow it yourself for free and without
having to Hanuman mo all the grass
instead of actually I'm doing what they
should be doing so that's pretty cool
but um that's very off topic I should
probably just do some path work now the
one and sole reason that I'm placing
this part over here is kind of to just
place lease path over here because I it
was just kind of boring right there no
there was nothing to see over there
behind the roller coaster this roller
coaster almost it almost feels like it's
built to be surrounded by other things
but it isn't or at least it wasn't so
I'm going to build trees and stuff
around this roller coaster make it look
a bit more good I suppose just the good
old read them what do they call these
things the redfers so I'm going to place
those excellent commentary isn't that a
commentary that everybody wants I'm
going to do this now I'm going to do
back watch in awe as I do this but yeah
that that's pretty much sure the order
of the day over here and there's a tree
in the way which is kind of stupid you
know it's either that or making vagina
jokes well not really but and that's the
point
I still don't have anything else there's
the miniature railroad which is also
something that I don't want have I keep
getting these transport rice but it's
not really something that i often use
the monorail is pretty cool though I
could actually do something with this
seriously I'm going to try this I'm
going to make like a cool little area
over here and surrounded with a monorail
rarely have ever done anything like that
but no might as well try some new things
now because this is roller coaster
tycoon one and we can't use shifts to
raise other things I'm going to have to
use this you know still it might
actually work out well and this monorail
can actually fill up the emptiness that
we have over here so that's really cool
and I'll place trees later on there's
just something about just having barely
any trees in your Park when you get it
but for some reason every single tree
that is there just stands in the way one
way or another that just always happens
doesn't it ok so I'm going to move this
around that actually more like that and
this seems kind of awkward in a sense I
don't want to make it to square so now
slightly move it around that and back
there
and no wait actually not I'm gonna place
it even further over there pretty high
over there but whatever i can i can do
that and it's all diagonal part like
that and going around that and then this
is going to be one big area of fun now i
don't know if i can buy the land over
there but i don't think i can nope I
can't so that's there's something about
being too close to the park board oh
that I don't really like so I kind of
want to stay at least one time away from
that and i don't think i can buy the
land of oh I can buy that land good
that's very nice that land is not for
sale though so I'm going to have to do
the curve like this remove some of the
trees and then we're done here I think
now just having one station on this
monorail seems a bit stupid so make sure
you get a place in another station right
over here and this station is five tiles
big so this one should be two that's
three that's five and the colors are
still stupid but definitely going to do
something about that okay so this is
going to be the new area of the pike or
at least and that's the planning and I
think I'm actually going to change the
tiles I mean the path over here because
I don't really like this path as is
right now so I'm actually going to use
this thing which automatically removes
the benches for some reason which is
very unfortunate but oh well what can
you do about that
you have that bomb okay very nice now I
need to place the offences again to for
some stupid reason sometimes in this
game just like to being stupid more
offenses seriously i love this fence too
much maybe it's because of mel's world
because that's why this fence is are
used in this I'm way in the game already
but no there's just something about the
look of this sprite that I really like
the color of the monorail is I don't
know what to do with that let's change
the name of the monorail 12 just wanna
real no because in that's a little less
awkward still awkward but not quite as
awkward as that weird one at the end the
green is definitely too much like the
environments and we don't like the
environment might want to make it red
but then again red is perhaps a bit too
dark something like that is this aqua I
don't know I'm just gonna try it though
mmm mmm yeah it's still bit too bright
there's something about just finding
that balance between a very bright color
and the color that you know kind of goes
along with the environments because you
don't want to have it stand out too much
so I think I'm just gonna use brown and
so no wait the roller coaster is already
done so that that's kind of awkward to
UM damn this is hard what currently i'm
on the rails usually I just make it
great that would actually be kind of
funny like cotton said so wanna call it
let's just go with a not comment you
know what I'm gonna go with grey
whatever no one maker and this area too
bright
and an exit over there and turns over
there and an exit over there now let's
get rid of all these trees as i can
because now i'm going to transform this
entire area beyond belief so i
definitely need to clean this up first
and there we go gonna make a connection
with the path over here and the path
over here and i kind of want to play
some trees because you know this area is
kind of looking very bare right now and
I don't want that we get the bumper cars
which is just in time for this new area
it can be the first attraction of this
new new era of my Park ok let's try that
now in the middle of this I kind of want
to create like a little plaza or
something like this um we're over there
like that yeah ok and of course in the
middle of that I'm going to have a
fountain because what is a what is the
square without a fountain in the middle
right and I might actually want to
change the ground texture to don't
really know what too low suppose this
just this kind of earthy soil e-collar
kind of thing and place that fountain
we're gonna place the elephant fountain
because it's big and it's skewed and
it's cool then you can play some flowers
over there and supply was over there and
looking pretty generic you know what I
actually kind of do want to play some
grass over here it's that that brownish
color it's not really too appealing then
sick small small shrubs and sides like
do I even have the correct plate no
still don't have it okay there we go
that's what i wanted and i don't know if
i have any very small flowers yup i do
so that is perfect place those
we have a nice little square thingy this
thing might actually be too nice to
actually be very realistic oh well I
like it and let's go down then now I
can't do that right away over there so
I'm actually going to do the young
standard kind of thing like this which
is compact but I do like the look of it
so I'm just going to go for that and
this is going to connect the queue and
I'm gonna have a path from this place
going there as well and actually I'm
gonna add a small code to that otherwise
it's so straight don't really like
straight pants like that and I think
that's pretty cool what's out ok I
suppose it's actually a good idea to
start off with your general layout
before placing rides ok so the bumper
cars are going to be over here the
entrance is going to connect to the main
plaza because I don't really see another
solution to this or I could do like that
but I think it's better to connect it to
the main no actually no that makes the
queue way too short I'm actually gonna
do it like that open up these bumper
cars oh yes the awesome bumper car music
and change that color scheme because I
don't really like that bright red thing
that it's got going on there and this is
not really too great either think this
should do or perhaps a bit of her blog
there but then again there's already
purple in the roller coaster so I'm
doing oh that that is awkward way too
bright that's shade of purple yeah
that's great actually ok so glad we
settled on that and suppose a small
little fence around this thing before
people start ruining my beautiful
flowers and I'm very fond of flowers you
may know
and small little things but around this
and the Ducks because the Ducks are
amazing there we go and don't really
know what to do with this general area
but you know I'm just gonna play some
dolphins dolphins are also pretty cool
and the hedge for numerous reasons but
most of all because the Hodges are also
pretty cool and then are the things on
the sides which I'm just going to do
that like that nice lots of decorations
going on but that's really one I like
about this game sometimes and this thing
still needs an exit part i always forget
about that i always do and still thing
like that more trees definitely to fill
up the emptiness and even more puke is
accumulating on these parts is terrible
I'm definitely going to have to assign
this guy just for this area because this
roller coaster is sure is sickening to
the guests it seems okay there we go I
think this is a good moment to save
before I started losing everything very
nice yes yes just overwrite it okay do
we get anything else yet we get the
water slide which is completely useless
well that mean I don't have any space
for that you know it might actually be
time to place a maze or something like
that because I keep getting these
terrible things or a turn of the gentle
rides at least because I have a fit I
feel that I should get more thrill rides
but I just keep getting these things
that I know I just don't want
okay let's see is there any place then I
could actually build like some kind of
what to slide or something like that I
mean I could expand into this area I
still got a little over a year to
actually start doing stuff because right
now it's October the eighth so I have a
bit of an October and another year to
work on stuff which might be just enough
to work in this area but I'm not sure
whether it will now last couple of
months I didn't make profit but before I
did I did so at least in terms of the
money department I'm not doing as as
terrible as I thought I would so you
know what I'm actually going to do the
campaign for free entry to the park even
though the park is already free haha so
I'm going to try that and ya know I
could actually place the maze or the car
ride I could actually do that even
though I don't like these things and and
and there's the pre-built mazes but you
know they don't really feel like that
though too awesome so you know I'm going
to have to built the custom design so
that's how hardcore I am but I'm still
going to finish this little thing before
I do that because otherwise it might
actually turn into a chaotic little
thing over here and I'm gonna make that
a path and I don't think there's any
room left for a real flat right over
here so I'm honestly just be done with a
maze over there
II now that's going to be the exit part
from the maze which is going to hook up
over over there so the maze is going to
start about let's say here yeah right
and before I do anything else I'm just
going to have to like wait wait wait
wait wait what alright i'm just going to
build the general size of the maze where
I kind of want to have it and this maze
is not going to be a square because
square mazes are for the lame people and
the exit is going to be right over there
and we can get it expanded over there
and remove that part not that part
though oops well that was not what I was
supposed to do just remove that little
point and I think this is going to be
the maze okay so entrance over there
exit over there small path to the exit
and a small park to the entrance and I
think we're done here now no we're
definitely not done with this I still
need to kind of make the maize itself
sadly okay let's see let's get a good
view of this now let's not make things
too complicated but let's also not put
too much time into this maze sometimes I
am really enthusiastic about my mazes
and I stood doing all these interesting
patterns and all that but I really feel
like this is not the right time for that
and oops that was also not the right
time to do that and let's see that's
build more pieces over here and over
there and actually no let's do that
I should also keep in mind that this
maze should actually be possible so I'm
I need to hook it up somewhere and the
path to date and to the accident is
going to be right over here rights and
let's see like that but I'm going to
fill that up and built this oh yes I am
a genius an evil genius that is ok so
here we go that's the maze it's not
really the best maze I've ever made it's
gonna be called the maze very
appropriate title nobody's going to be
misled by this title and that's pretty
much that ride now some smaller
ornamental trees around this because we
always need some ornamental trees and I
suppose we need some of these are cool
bears over here all the dogs get their
dogs but whatever we need our squirrels
anyway not much cooler and i think
that's it yeah i'm just going to play
some small trees over here and then call
it a day then place of the sum of these
standard redfers over here and of course
just redfers everywhere because that
beautiful
and is this a spruce oh also referred
whatever so I'm going to place that too
and another foe and ground shrubbery
before I forget it and then I'm going to
move on oh yes that that bumper cars
music so great and I think we're done
here let's open up the monorail we have
the large cars but they're kind of ugly
so I'm just going to open it like this
don't have any test results yet the
trains though oh wait that's that's two
trains for bracelets so that's okay
that's not going to cause any problems
and make the bottom red or something
like that and the top blue and the
bottom white and then till actually I do
like that I'm just going to do it like
that ok so I still need to fill up this
area with something might be a station
of a right of some sort or something
else but I figure out something yeah the
park is not looking too bad at the
moment so in the next episode I'm going
to do something of which I have no idea
what i'm going to do yet i'm i'm getting
the river rapids monocle I want to do
something like that they're actually
very scenery theme of all so I want to
try that but anyway oh thanks for
watching and see you on the next episode